bonjour à tous Depuis hier les sénateur
examine le projet de loi de
programmation pour la ville et la
cohésion urbaine un texte de François
lamis un texte qui a pour objectif de
réduire les inégalités entre les
quartiers sensibles et les autres
territoires et d'améliorer les
conditions de vie des habitants de ces
quartiers d'octobre 2012 à janvier 2013
s'est tenue une large concertation sur
le sujet concertation à laquelle ont
participé de nombreux sénateurs comme le
rapporteur socialiste du texte Claude
dyin ou bien encore la sénatrice
centriste Valérie léard ou la communiste
Laurence Cohen de cette large
concertation et bien est né ce texte ce
texte qui a pour objectif de refonder
entièrement la politique de la ville
d'éviter le saupoudrage des crédits de
l'État pour s'attaquer au quartier le
plus pauvre d'éviter un énième plan
Marshal pour de réelles solutions
structurelles de long terme tout de
suite donc retour aux discussions qui se
sont tenues hier soir au
Sénat nous reprenons la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale après engagement
accéléré de programmation pour la ville
et la cohésion urbaine dans la
discussion des articles nous sommes
parvenus à l'amendement numéro 49 au
sein de l'article
1er cet amendement est présenté par
Madame
Benbassa cet amendement vise à assurer à
la fois la bonne information des
parlementaires quant à l'évolution des
quartiers prioritaires de la politique
de la ville et à veiller à ce qu'un
débat annuel puisse se tenir quant à
l'adéquation de la politique de la ville
menée au déploiement des crédits ainsi
qu'au modalités de sa mise en œuvre pour
atteindre les objectifs fixés ce débat
annuel avec les parlementaires est
essenti afin de garantir la bonne
adéquation et la bonne utilisation des
crédits et de permettre une adaptation
régulière des stratégies adoptées
balance je vous remercie quel est l'avis
de la commission commission pense que ce
débat pourra avoir lieu en l'état actuel
donc c'est pas la peine de l'inscrire
dans la loi d'ailleurs l'année dernière
il y a eu un débat vous avez participé
donc on peut dire que c'est satisfait
donc avis défavorable ou
retrait quel est l'avis du ministre
oui monsieur le Président le
Gouvernement partage l'avis du
rapporteur d'autant plus que le le débat
a lieu en loi de finance bon et c'est le
moment essentiel pour effectivement
mesurer l'impact de la de la politique
de la ville donc je vous propose soit de
retirer l'amendement soit ça sera
défavorable bien
je monsieur raou vous souhaitez monsieur
le Président vous souhaitez
intervenir justement monsieur le
Président vous vous donnez vous venez de
donner le compte-rendu de la Commission
de la Conférence des Présidents et vous
verrez qu'il y a un certain nombre de
qod des questions orales avec débat et
dans lequel tous les groupes peuvent
s'inscrire dans leurs niches qui leur
sont attribuées et donc c'est pas dans
un texte de loi qu'on peut mettre ce
genre de d'implication et d'autre part
comme l'a dit monsieur le ministre c'est
aussi une évaluation au niveau de la loi
de finance qu'on regarde les crédits
affectés à chaque mission et donc c'est
dans ce cadre là que se situe
éventuellement le
débat madame Benbassa vous retirez votre
amendement donc l'amendement est
retiré je mets donc au voix l'article
1er qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'article 1er est
adopté j'en viens à l'article
1ier B a pour lequel j'ai une demande de
prise de parole de la part de Madame
Church pour le groupe
CC monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le présent
article permet l'élaboration d'un
rapport devant aboutir à la future
dotation ville au-delà de l'évolution
positive de son mode d'attribution nous
neoud pas que cette création constitue
juste un tour de passe-pe entre
l'actuelle dotation de développement
urbain et la future dotation ville nous
nous interrogeons alors sur l'utilité
d'une telle disposition qui relève au
fond principalement de la loi de
finances les modalités de cette future
dotation sont également à ce stade
particulièrement flou ce qui ne permet
pas aux parlementaires de légiférer dans
de bonnes conditions de plus nous
parlons au fond de sommes extrêmement
limité puisque la dotation de
développement urbain représente pour
l'année qui vient simplement 100
millions d'euros cette somme est
d'ailleurs à mettre en relation avec
l'extinction des zones franches urbaines
dont le coût au budget national est de
400 millions
d'euros même si leur utilité était
contestable et non avérée cette
extinction représente au fond des
économies substantielles pour le budget
de l'État qui serviront ou non nous ne
savons pas à réalimenter la politique de
la ville pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre
ne pas sanctuariser cette somme qui
alimenterait des actions spécifiques
pour le développement de l'emploi dans
les quartiers prioritaires je vous
remercie bien je suis saisi d'un
amendement numéro 7 qui est présenté par
monsieur Germain au nom de la commission
des
finances un amendement rédactionnel
monsieur le ministre quel est du
gouvernement avis favorable bien
je pardon commission ah oui la
Commission saisie au fond ça ira vite
monsieur le Président c'est un avis
favorable bien je vous remercie bien
donc je mets au voix cet amendement qui
est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient donc
l'amendement est adopté je mets donc au
voix l'article 1er B a ainsi amendé qui
est pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'article 1er B A est
adopté après l'article 1er B a je suis
saisi de deux amendements en discussion
commune le
prier article
26 est présenté par Monsieur Vanir
donc
Président on a vu récemment à l'occasion
de la discussion sur le texte concernant
le métropole les
euh que de plus en plus souvent les
métropoles et les communauté urbaines
exercé au nom et pour le compte de
l'état des délégations de compétences
venant de l'État c'est notamment vrai
rappelez-vous nos discussions sur les
aides à la
pierre donc
la l'article additionnel qui vous est
proposé ici pense que l'État sans perdre
une seule prérogative en terme
d'appréciation des conditions d'emploi
de ces crédits spécifiques de la
politique de la ville pourrait
envisager une délégation de gestion aux
communautés urbaines et au métropole ce
qui aurait l'immense mérite de de le
débarrasser des tâches
administratives
d'instruction purement formel des
dossiers je pense aux fonctions de
greffe du contrat de ville et je ne vous
cache pas que l'intention des
cignataires est de pouvoir libérer
toutes les marges de manœuvre des
préfets délégués à la politique de la
ville pour leur cœur de métier qui doit
être la mobilisation et
du droit commun voilà le résumé de cette
proposition bien je vous remercie
l'amendement de rectifier présenté par
Monsieur BCO peut-être oui monsieur le
Président chers collègues écoutez il
s'agit du même amendement exactement au
mot près donc je le propose de la même
façon il a déjà été à l'instant défendu
bon il se ressemble beaucoup mais je je
le prends comme comme tel mais voilà
bien quel est l'avis de la la commission
Commission donne un avis défavorable
parce qu'elle considère que là il y a
peut-être un un contresens parce queun
telle délégation pour pas dire une telle
déconcentration est contraire à une des
lignes de force de la politique de la
ville qu le contrat c'estàd qu'on
délègue pas de l'argent enfin des
subventions et puis après on en fait ce
qu'on en veut on onl on met à
disposition des collectivitésoriales des
des subventions pour faire quelque chose
qui est inscrit dans le contrat donc là
ça nous paraît contradictoire avec ça et
la commission a donné un avis
défavorable quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement sur cet amendement je vais
vous le donner monsieur le Président mon
monsieur le sénateur je suis un peu
surpris de de de cet amendement parce
que tout tout l'enjeu de de ce projet de
loi et la façon dont il a été fabriqué
c'était d'abord d'engager une
concertation avec l'ensemble des élus
des responsables associatifs des
professionnels de la politique de la
ville or jamais cette proposition n'
n'est sortie n' surgi de de de la
concertation donc voilà déjà par
principe par rapport à la à la
construction de ce ce ce projet de loi
je ne pourrais pas y être favorable la
deuxième chose c'est que cette cette
proposition est totalement incompatible
avec l'article 1 que vous avez adopté
tout à l'heure qui dit que la politique
de la ville est une politique de
solidarité nationale voilà déléguer
complètement en fait parce que la la
réalité c'est déléguer complètement les
crédits donc en fait les capacités
d'intervention politique de au au
métropole c'est ce serait privé de
l'état de sa capacité de de de pouvoir
intervenir sur sur les contenus en lien
bien entendu avec les collectivités
territoriales donc c'est pour ça que je
suis je suis opposé à à à cet amendement
que le gouvernement y est opposé
d'autant plus que dans la réalité je
sais bien je dire d' vousis pu émerger
cet amendement puisque je pense à tout
particulièrement à l'agglomération
lyonnaise bon les choses se passent bien
dans l'agglomération lyonnaise et
l'agglomération lyonnaise est la preuve
qu'effectivement un bon un bon compromis
une bonne un bon travail entre une une
une intercommunalité forte qui sait
organiser sa politique de la ville avec
les les collectivités et l'État produit
d'excellents résultats et donc je
propose d'en rester là
quoi bien monsieur dir
donc j'accepte de retirer cet amendement
bien et Monsieur becco retirer également
cet amendement bien donc les deux
amendements sont retirés je vous
remercie l'article 1er bis est
supprimé nous en venons à l'article 2
avec une demande de parole de
madame oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le présent article est particulièrement
important il prolonge de 2 ans le
programme national de rénovation urbaine
il permet le lancement d'un nouveau
programme de renouvellement urbain et
enfin il complète les missions et le
financement de l'enrue nous ne pouvons
que nous féliciter du lancement d'un
PNRU 2 sur la période
2014-2024 attendu depuis longtemps et
promis par le candidat Holland
nous nous félicitons également
qu'aujourd'hui et par ce projet de loi
la problématique des copropriétés soit
enfin prise en compte et que la
terminologie de renouvellement urbain
est supplantée celle de rénovation
urbaine nous sommes satisfaits de la
méthode qui a été la votre monsieur le
ministre celle de la concertation nous
adhérons enfin votre volonté d'associer
les populations sur les opérations de
renouvellement urbain cela correspond à
une nécessité nous avons tous à l'esprit
le souvenir de la la détresse de
certains habitants devant la démolition
de leurs immeuble auquel ils étaient
attachés cette démarche mérite d'être
saluer et nous la soutenons pour autant
nous sommes dubitatifs sur le montant
escompté pour ce nouveau programme
puisque'avec 5 milliards d'euros
celui-ci sera plus de deux fois moindre
que le premier programme il sera
exclusivement dédié au quartier relevant
de la nouvelle géographie prioritaire
qui est nettement resserrée et nous
craignons que cette définition stricte
pénalise au final les communes et les
quartiers qui restent extrêmement
fragile et pour lequel le financement
d'opération de renouvellement urbain
reste cependant une nécessité d'autre
part si nous considérons que la
prolongation du premier PN rue est rendu
nécessaire par la lenteur de la mise de
sa mise en œuvre nous considérons
qu'outre la nécessité d'une prolongation
cela devrait au fond nous interroger sur
les blocages qui ont conduit à ces
retards nous craignons dans le contexte
de rétraction de l'action publique et
des moyens des collectivités que
celle-ci peineent à participer au
financement dans le cadre du nouveau
programme de renouvellement urbain et ce
ne sont pas les annonces du président de
la République cet après-midi qui vont
nous rassurer je rappelle également le
niveau extrêmement faible de la
participation de l'État au financement
direct de la politique de la ville ce
qui constitue à nos yeux un problème
majeur c'est d'ailleurs le 1 % qui
finance à titre principal en rue à
hauteur de 810 millions par an le rôle
premier du 1 % qui n'est pas n'est pas
de palier aux défaillances de l'État
mais bien de financer la production de
logement social pour les salariés nous
craignons également que la baisse
annoncée du taux du livra pénalise la
récolte de l'épargne populaire et par
voie de conséquence ne permettent pas à
la Caisse de dépôt de jouer pleinement
son rôle de financeur
nous pouvons par ailleurs contester la
possibilité nouvelle offerte par
l'article 2 de ce projet de loi de la
possibilité donnée à l'enrue de créer
des filiales avec des opérateurs privés
censé attirer des investisseurs privés
cette possibilité certes financé
exclusivement au travers des
investissements d'avenir à hauteur de
250 millions d'euros ne semble pas
correspondre au aux modalités d'action
de l'enrue qui doit rester dans le rôle
de financeur et non d'acteur propre du
Renou ement urbain voilà donc les
éléments monsieur le ministre que nous
souhaitons au préalable de la discussion
vous faire
partager je suis saisi de deux
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune tout d'abord
l'article l'amendement 14 rectifié qui
est présenté par Monsieur Favier
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues par cet
amendement nous souhaitons poser une
question importante si nous acons comme
Madame chersch vient de le dire très
favorablement le lancement du PNR du PNR
U2 nous estimons au préalable qu'il
convient évidemment de mener un bilan du
premier programme dans ce cadre force de
constater que la mise en œuvre de ce
programme de renouvellement s'il a
permis on le sait une amélioration de la
vie d'un certain nombre de quartiers
reste marqué quand même par au moins de
insuffisance la première sa réalisation
n'est à ce jour que partielle et ce qui
a conduit effectivement le gouvernement
donc a allongé le délai de réalisation
de 2 ans et deuxièmement nous avons pu
constater un déséquilibre dans les
actions différentes qui ont été financé
par l'enrue ainsi dans le cadre des
conventions conclues sous lesgide donc
du premier programme
144692 logements ont été détruits et
140842 ont été produits a TR bandit donc
il y a eu évidemment plus de logements
détruits que de logements construits
pourê clair nous estimons évidemment
qu'au regard de la crise du logement
extrêmement grave que nous vivons
aujourd'hui que nous traversons il n'est
pas envisageable évidemment que dans le
cadre de ce deuxè programme nous
puissions continuer évidemment dans
cette dans cette voie le nombre de
production le de logement doit être
évidemment au moins égal à celui des
démolitions c'est bien là le minimum et
en tout cas par exemple pour ma part je
serais même favorable à ce qu'il soit
assez nettement même supérieur le nombre
de logements reconstruits que des
logements euh détruits ça n'est pas
impossible on a des tas d'exemples où
euh dans certaines villes effectivement
les maires ont euh accepté et euh
d'aller plus loin effectivement que le 1
pour un et ont reconstruit plus de
logement effectivement que de logement
euh détruit pour cette raison euh nous
proposons donc par cet amendement de
l'inscrire donc dans la loi de manière
très claire alors que nous allons
revenir dans quelques jours sur le
projet de loi allure il semble que le
projet de loi sur la ville donc doit
prendre en compte évidemment l'urgence
aussi euh de contribuer à travers
également ce son action de répondre
aussi à ce besoin donc pour répondre au
besoins donc de cette crise du logement
et de ce déficit aujourd'hui dont nous
souffrons monsieur dillain vous nous
proposez l'article le l'amendement 86 au
nom de la commission des affaires
économiques si vous le permettez
monsieur le Président je vais en
profiter pour donner mon l'avis de la
commission sur sur l'amendement 14 alors
dans une une première version qui était
du un pour un euh qui éit un peu rigide
la la la Commission avait donné un avis
défavorable mais comme il y a une
rectification très importante et que
cette rectification correspond tout à
fait à l'amendement 86 que je veux
défendre maintenant c'est-à-dire que la
la reconstruction doit tenir
effectivement compte des des besoins
structurels en logements sociaux fixés
dans le cadre des programmes locaux de
l'abita là il y a une c'est exactement
le même amendement donc je je vais
donner un avis favorable puisque la
commission a donné un avis favorable au
mien donc voilà bien monsieur le
ministre quel est votre avis sur ces
deux
amendements ah non oui pardon monsieur
le Président je partage la la vidéo
rapporteur donc voilà ça va me permettre
de de de répondre quand même à Madame
chersch par rapport à à son
intervention en débat général sur sur
l'article d'une part moi je je je
partage votre avis sur la question des
démolitions voilà et moi je souhaite que
dans à la fois dans la dans la fin du
plan national de rénovation urbaine 1 et
dans le le nouveau PNRU on on regarde
plus particulièrement la question des
démolitions on est limitant d'une part
aux immeubles qui dont la structure ne
permet plus effectivement de de les
rénover et et d'autre part aux
démolition nécessaires pour un
désenclavement des quartiers voilà
lorsque vous avez besoin de faire passer
un s propre de transport en commun un
tramois ou d'ouvrir je pense à certaines
cités besoin d'ouvrir la cité sur son
environnement extérieur voilà mais
qu'après on soit en capacité je pense
que on a évolué maintenant sur le la
facilité de la possibilité de d'avoir
des des des rénovations et des
réhabilitations lourdes qui permettent
effectivement au locataires de de de
rester voir même de et d'améliorer bien
entendu leur leur situation c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que je vais anis au au
mois d'avril quatre rencontres urbaines
auxquelles d'ailleurs les les élus
seront invités avec des urbanistes des
architectes des professionnels pour
qu'on soit en capacité de de réfléchir
sur le nouveau plan de renouvellement
urbain voilà en ce qui concerne le le le
le la question de la réalisation de
l'actuel PNRU faut pas oublier quand
même quelques quelques facteurs d'autre
part d'une part le fait que comme on est
sur des financements croisé vous pouvez
avoir à la fois des collectivités
territoriales qui ne peuvent pas suivre
ne peuvent pas suivre l'enrue vous
pouvez avoir aussi des bailleurs qui
sont dans cette situation vous avez
aussi des fois des problèmes matériels
ou des problèmes techniques je pense
entre autres à la découverte d'amiante
voà qui non seulement ralentissent mais
alourdissent le coût financier de la de
la réhabilitation bon l'ensemble de ces
facteurs bon et puis un dernier facteur
que tout le monde oublie c'est que il y
a eu beaucoup de Ch ement de
municipalité en 2008 et que les
programmes ont été révisés euh et donc
ça Alourd le le le déchéancier de du
plan national de rénovation urbaine 1
voilà donc tout ceci explique qu'on ait
besoin de d'aller jusqu'en 2015 mais à
part quelques
cas précis j'ai pas d'inquiétude sur la
réalisation potentielle en tout cas ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas un problème
financier de la part de de de l'anrue
voilà sur la sur le financement du du de
de de l'EN rue bon nous sommes sur un
financement croisé j'allais me permettre
cette faéci à madame la sénatrice en
vous disant ce soir que après tout le
socialisme voir le communisme c'est
quand même d'aller chercher l'argent là
où il est voilà et que personne ne se
plaindra du fait que les partenaires
sociaux et tout particulièrement le
patronat finance le logement social en
tout cas pas vous ni moi voilà bon
l'important c'est que nous ayons
l'important c'est que nous ayons un
cocktail équilibré et que nous soyons en
capacité
de pouvoir garder la maîtrise politique
de de l'ensemble de de ce programme
voilà quand à finir sur le le rôle de de
l'enrue en matière de de développement
économique et de participation au
capital d'entreprise spécialement dédié
je reste je encore je je le rappelle on
est bien dans le cadre d'opération de
développement économique avec un
financement spécifique du plan
investissement d'avenir en ce qui
concerne le développement économique des
quartiers voilà donc ça ne n'obert pas
du tout bien entendu la suite de des
opérations de rénovation urbaine quoi
voilà némoins je monsieur rapporteur sur
l'amendement monsieur Dalier vous avez
la parole pour explication de
vote merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
écoutez moi je ne me lancerai pas dans
une tentative de définition du
socialisme et du communisme surtout
après la conférence de presse de cet
après-midi alors je vais me contenter je
vais me contenter de m'en tenir au aux
deux amendements identiques qui nous
sont présentés et pour vous dire dire
que je je finis par me demander quel est
le quel est le but recherché parce que
que dit l'alinéa 12 je le relis si la
qualification des quartiers prioritaires
le nécessite ces interventions peuvent
être conduites à proximité de ceci la
production de logements locatifs sociaux
financé dans le cadre du nouveau
programme national de renouvellement
urbain s'effectue dans les unités
urbaines auxquelles appartiennent les
quartiers concernés par ce programme
qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire ici et
qu'est-ce qu'on avait voulu dire lors du
premier programme c'est qu'effectivement
l'objectif c'était du un pour un mais on
avait aussi acté l'idée que il était pas
absolument et toujours nécessaire que le
1 pour un soit reconstruit dans le
quartier lui-même on avait quand même et
je pensais que tout le monde était
d'accord mis en évidence la nécessité de
mixité sociale donc on a essayé
d'attirer des promoteurs de faire de
l'accession sociale du logement
intermédiaire donc on a parfois décidé
de reconstruire ailleurs et dans ma
commune au Pavillon sous-bois il y a eu
des reconstructions qui ont été compté
du un pour un avec des tion à se vend si
ma mémoire est bonne ça me semble de
bonne logique et je pense qu'il ne faut
pas sortir de là il faut pas
effectivement revenir à une règle strict
alors que dit l'amendement et c'est là
où tout d'un coup j'ai un doute on nous
dit donc on nous propose de compléter
laanilé à 12 que je viens de lire par la
phrase suivante ce programme doit
garantir une reconstitution de l'offre
de logement locatif social démoli
compatible avec les besoins structurels
en logement locatifs sociaux fixés par
les programmes locaux de l'habitat oups
euh d'abord je vous dire que c'est un
peu compliqué un peu compliqué à
comprendre maintenant si on se situe
dans la mais attendez mon cher collègue
dyin si on se situe dans la métropole du
Grand Paris en première couronne
qu'est-ce que c'est que la traduction
concrète de ce qui est écrit ici moi
j'ai un peu j'ai un peu j'ai un peu de
mal à comprendre
jusqu'où peut-être mais j'ai un peu de
mal à comprendre l'application très
concrète si ça nous pousse effectivement
à considérer que démolition à l'Est on
peut effectivement les recomptabiliser
n'importe où ailleurs dans la métropole
pourquoi pas je voudrais être certain
que la lecture soit exactement celle-là
si c'est le cas ça va plutôt dans la
bonne direction maintenant mais
confirmez-le moi maintenant sur le 1
pour un pour avoir conduit un rapport il
y a quelques années sur l'en rue je suis
allé en province voir des
opérations qualifié en rue mais qui qui
n'avait rien à voir avec les opérations
les plus importantes qu'est-ce qu'on
pouvait constater sur place qu'il y
avait parfois des logements locatifs
sociaux vides ça existait alors je dis
ça pour répondre à nos collègues qui
s'étonnent que le 1 pour1 ne soit pas
exactement au rendez-vous alors tout
d'abord on n'est pas au bout des
opération il y a encore des des
logements à construire mais il y a aussi
des endroits où on a démoli dans le
cadre de l'EN rue 1 parce que sur le
territoire de et à proximité on était en
surcapacité donc là aussi en conclusion
ne soyons pas trop strict il faut un peu
de souplesse pour adapter les décisions
au territoire al je veux bien après vous
avoir entendu mais j'attends quand même
lire cet amendement comme allant dans ce
sens mais j'ai quand même un petit doute
hein pour tout dire mon le rapporteur
vous souhaitez
intervenir merci monsieur le Président
oui alors l'exemple que vous avez
soulevé me va parfaitement bien puisque
effectivement ça va ça va dans ce sens
dans le sens que vous dites alors je
vous critiquez la forme ça je je la
défendrai pas si vous la critiquez mais
sur le fond c'est exactement ce que vous
voulez dire c'est-à-dire que le dans la
région î-de-france c'est dans la loi que
vous connaissez bien le le PLH c'est le
plan métropolitain de l'habitat et de
l'hébergement donc le et qui fixe des
objectifs ici et là dans la métropole et
donc effectivement lorsqu'il y a une
opération de renouvellement urbain s'il
y a des démolutions elles doivent être
les reconstructions doivent se faire
dans le cadre fixé par le PLH
c'est-à-dire pas forcément institu c'est
exactement ça qu'on vous
dire
bien j'ai une demande de parole de
Madame
léard juste 2 secondes pour compléter
les arguments de monsieur le rapporteur
et pour éclairer aussi notre collègue
philippe Dallier parce qu'effectivement
nous avons eu un débat qui n'apparaît
est pas ici mais en commission des
affaires économiques justement qui
portait sur un premier débat et de
premiers amendements de Madame Church
qui ont évolué suite au débat et aux
propositions de Monsieur dylin et
effectivement au départ on était plutôt
sur une logique d'amendement qui allent
dans ce sens c'était dans le cadre de ce
programme national les opérations de
production de logement sont au moins
égale à celle de démolition c'était ce
que vous ne vouliez pas monsieur Dalier
et justement la rédaction y compris de
Madame Church qui a qui qui a amélioré
son amendement sur les recommandations
de Monsieur dylin et en cohérence avec
monsieur dylin était de dire exactement
ce que vient de dire philippe Dallier
aussi à savoir je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord c'est on doit maintenir une
production de logements sociaux qui soit
la hauteur effectivement des démolitions
parce qu'on a un vrai besoin dans ce
domaine mais comme vient de le dire à
juste titre monsieur Dalier mais ça
rejoint exactement le débat de la
commission il faut effectivement le
faire là où c'est véritablement utile
pour maintenir une mixité sociale et
éviter de la vacance de logement là où
effectivement il n'est plus nécessaire
de produire du logement social au même
endroit donc tout ceci pour dire que
mais on peut comprendre que ceux qui
n'ont pas participé à la commission n'ai
pas vu cette subtilité et ne comprennent
pas la motivation de ces deux
amendements voilà donc en fait on est
tous d'accord bon je ne vois plus
d'autrre demande d'explication de vote
donc je vais pouvoir mettre au vote ces
amendement 14 rectifié 86 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient les
amendements sont adoptés j'en viens donc
à l'amendement 73 rectifié qui est
présenté par Monsieur V DIREN
donc bon c'est un amendement sur lequel
madame lard pourra aussi se retrouver
hein puisque quand on est originaire
d'une région qui a quand même marquée
par par
les mutations des trois principales
mono-industries issues du 19e siècle on
sait très bien que la majorité des
quartiers
prioritaires vont se trouver àollés à
des friche industriel friches
industrielle ou ici même à l'origine du
Sénat d'ailleurs et de plusieurs de mes
collègues euh on a essayé de donner un
statut à l'occasion de la loi allure
donc je voulais juste
avoir une
précision dans l'alinéa
13 en question pour bien montrer si on
pouvait ajouter après les mots activité
économique et commercial que la
reconquête des friches et bien éligible
potentiellement au financement pour le
renouvellement urbain de
l'enrue bien quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur dyan
euh avec beaucoup de tristesse je vais
encore dire à Monsieur van derendung de
de retirer son amendement parce que il
nous semble que la Linéa 13 est déjà
très claire là-dessus puisqu'on parle
d'un
aménagement du territoire et et citant
effectivement déjà toutes les
possibilités et et donc pour moi ça
implique de façon claire les friches
industriel donc il y a dans la loi
actuellement pour l'aménageur la
possibilité de de prendre les les
friches industrielles donc enfin moi je
veux bien qu'on le rajoute mais ça sera
exactement la même chose quoi ça ne
donnera rien de plus à la
loi ministre quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement
oui je monsieur le Président je partage
l'avis du du rapporteur la les friches
elles vont être prises en compte
d'ailleurs dans la géographie
prioritaire parce que c'est vrai c'est
une une spécificité de de votre région
et j'y fais j'y fais très très attention
puisque je sais d'ailleurs que ça peut
fausser la carte de la géographie
prioritéire donc on est en train de de
regarder cela mais effectivement à
partir du moment où on est dans un
quartier prioritaire de la politique de
la ville l'enrue peut financer des
équipement public des réhabilitations
des reconstructions et bien entendu s'il
y a une friche au milieu la valoriser
donc je considère que l'amendement est
satisfait au regard du texte donc
oui monsieur V donc suis tout prêt à à
le retirer dès lors que il restera la
trace du procèsverbal et le fait fa que
les coûts inhérents aux
dépollution
démolition recyclage c'est-à-dire retour
sur le marché à des coûts comparables
sont éligibles à l' rue je remercie tant
le rapporteur que le ministre d'avoir
apporté cette importante
précision bien l'amendement 73 rectifié
retiré l'amendement numéro 9 suivant
n'est pas défendu j'en viens à
l'amendement 51 présenté par Madame
benbassard pour le groupe
écologiste la transition ég énergétique
et écologique de notre société passe par
un programme ambitieux de rénovation
thermique des bâtiments le PNRU 2 doit
donc tenir compte de cet objectif de
performance énergétique des bâtiment
mais aussi du bâti urbain mobilier et
cetera il doit également privilégier les
mat les plus écologiques et participer
aux politiques visant à une meilleure
qualité de l'air en intérieur et en
extérieur la biodiversité étant une
politique transversale sa préservation
et sa reconquête doivent également être
pris en compte lors des opérations de
rénovation l'objet de cet amendement est
donc d'assurer une vraie prise en compte
des enjeux énergétiques et de qualité
écologique du bâti dans le cadre d'
d'une politique de la ville
rénovée quel est l'avis de la commission
monsieur
dyin l'avis de la commission dit que là
la préoccupation de Madame Benbassa est
satisfait en particulier par les deux
amendements qui ont été adoptés par le
Sénat tout à l'heure donc là vraiment
moi je vous demande le retrait parce que
là on est quand même dans quelque chose
de très précis de très contraignant
alors que ces préoccupations ont déjà
été acceptées dans le texte monsieur le
ministre quel est votre votre avis oui
monsieur le Président même avec le
rapporteur y compris le texte actuel qui
parle de la transition énergétique
reprend bien entendu puis que nous
sommes d'accord sur ce qui est la
transition énergétique donc ça passe par
un ensemble et donc voilà l'amendement
est
satisfait madame
benbassard retrait non vous maintenez
vous m je je mets au voix cet amendement
51 qui qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas
adopté nous en sommes à l'amendement 65
rectifié qui est présenté par Monsieur
daller merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise à revenir sur une
disposition qui a été introduite par nos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale et
qui dit à cet article 2 à la Linéa 23
qui liste tous les domaines
d'intervention de l'agence alors je vais
pas les les citer tous hein mais
démolition réhabilitation
résidentialisation construction et
cetera nos collègues députés ont
souhaité rajouter les actions portant
sur l'histoire et la mémoire des
quartiers honnêtement je ne sais pas et
je ne vois pas en quoi l'agence est
directement concernée par cela à
l'article 1er et cela figure en toute
lettrre à la l'alinéa 15 il est bien dit
effectivement que la politique de la
ville doit viser à connaître et à
valoriser l'histoire le patrimoine et la
mémoire des quartiers c'est une bonne
chose parce qu'on sait bien pour ceux
qui on conduit des projets en rue
qu'effectivement lorsqu'on on va démolir
un certain nombre d'immeubles c'est
souvent vécu comme un traumatisme et les
habitants des quartiers sont
effectivement attachés à ce que l'on
conserve la mémoire des lieux il y a eu
des endroits où effectivement il y a eu
du travail fait sur le sujet avec les
gamins à l'école certains ont constitué
des documents pour la mémoire tout cela
c'est très bien et ça peut s'inscrire
dans un contrat de ville mais demander à
l'agence spécifiquement de financer ces
interventions là honnêtement ça me
semble aller un peu trop loin on peut
tout à fait le faire par ailleurs mais
ça n'est pas à l'agence qui doit
vraiment se spécialiser sur tout ce qui
concerne le bâti de se concentrer et
donc je propose de de supprimer cette
cette précision apportée par nos
collègues députés sans pour autant je
pense ça empêche le travail de cette
nature avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
la la commission a donné un avi
défavorable parce que cette disposition
a été adoptée à l'unanimé pas l'unan
pardon largement euh par l'Assemblée
nationale et je crois que c'est quelque
chose de très important effectivement
comme vous le dites vous-même de garder
la mémoire d'ailleurs il y a une demande
très forte des habitants dans les
discussions qu'on a eu pendant les
auditions c'est ressorti assez assez
nettement donc je pense que là il s'agit
en plus de somme modeste je pense je me
souviens pour l'avoir vu dans euh le la
première partie enfin la PNRU 1 comme on
dit que rue s'est déjà impliqué dans des
opérations de ce type et à mon avis à
juste titre c'était sur clichi
monfermail donc j'en suis sûr et à juste
titre et je crois qu'il faut pas revenir
là-dessus parce que ça fait partie
intégrante madame Church il a fait
allusion tout à l'heure et effectivement
sur le terrain c'est ça qu'on qu'on
constate donc je demande le retrait
Monsieur D monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le Président c'est c'est un
avis totalement défavorable que je
voudrais prononcer parce qu'il va
totalement à l'encontre de esprit et de
la lre de ce projet de loi qui qui fait
que la les les opérations de
renouvellement urbain ne sont pas
indissociabl des opérations de de de de
cohésion sociale et et la question de de
la mémoire en fait partie on peut pas
considérer que les uns sont chargés de
la démolition de la restructuration du
renouvellement urbain ainsi suite et les
autres seraient chargés des actions de
cohésion sociale de mémoire de lien
entre les habitants voilà c'est un tout
bon et c'est VI que lorsque on procède
comme vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs à une
un renouvellement urbain à l'intérieur
d'un quartier il y a un vrai traumatisme
voilà une vraie violence voilà j'ai j'ai
été pour ma part je pense entre autres à
à venicieux où les habitants vous
expliquent que ça fait 30 ans 30 ans que
que l'on procède au renouvellement du du
du quartier ça fait quasiment deux
générations qui sont qui sont concernés
par cela la question de de la mémoire du
bâti et des habitants
du bâti des habitants et du territoire
auquel ils appartiennent y compris avant
même que ce bâti est existé parce que je
crois que c'est un c'est un tout voilà
est une chose majeure et je vois pas
pourquoi l'agence nationale de
rénovation urbaine ne participerait pas
voilà dans le cadre entre autres des
maisons de projet au fait de de de
participer aux actions de de mémoire du
quartier du territoire et de ses
habitants bien monsieur Dalier pour
explication de vote monsieur le ministre
vous êtes totalement défavorable mais le
gouvernement n'y avait pas pensé puisque
ce sont nos collègues de l'Assemblée qui
l'ont introduit par voie d'amendement
euh bon ceci étant dit encore une fois
euh je n'ai je suis tout à fait
conscient qu'il est intéressant de faire
ce travail sur la mémoire des quartiers
ceci étant dit la mémoire c'est vivant
la mémoire de ces quartiers elle ne
s'arrêtera pas au bout du Projet de
Renouvellement Urbain donc on pourrait
tout à fait financer ce type de
d'opération par ailleurs sans demander à
l'agence de le faire spécifiquement
voilà vous savez quand on commence à se
disperser on prend toujours des risques
parce qu'on sait où où ça commence et on
se demande jusqu'où ça va aller donc
l'agence a les sommes toutes très
spécialisé moi je pensais
qu'effectivement il était pas utile
d'ajouter cela maintenant si Claude dyin
me dit que ça c'est déjà fait par le
passé écoutez je le découvre et que
peut-être que d'autres le découvriront
bon je vais pas en faire une affaire et
je vais retirer cet
amendement
monsieur le
ministre juste pour préciser préciser à
Monsieur D que à l'Assemblée c'est à la
suite d'un amendement gouvernemental que
nous avons intégré cette
disposition
bien monsieur le ministre si vous voulez
bien nous présenter l'amendement 81 pour
le
gouvernement
oui monsieur le monsieur le Président il
s'agit d'une reprise d'un amendement qui
n'a pas été
accepté à cause de l'article 40 qui
prévoyait un amendement madame bembassa
qui qui prévoyit le fait qu'on réserve 1
% de des des montants des des opérations
de renouvellement urbain lié à la
participation citoyenne à la
concertation et à la construction des
construction des projets al c'est vrai
que le 1 % fait c'est une référence
historique bon voilà ça pouvait être
intéressant en même temps on regarde les
volume
concerné le on voit par exemple le
PNRU de clich souois c'est 600 millions
d'euros consacré 6 millions d'euros à à
la concertation sur la ville de clichis
sousbois même le maire de l'ancien maire
de clichine n'aurait pas dans ses rêves
les foufous n'y aurait pas pensé mais
néanmoins il faut pouvoir garder
l'esprit et donc l'idée c'est
qu'effectivement on a des concours
financiers de l'an rue au dispositifs de
coconstruction des des projets de
renouvellement urbain avec les habitants
qui s'agisse notamment entre autres des
maisons de du projet des conseils
citoyens et en conformité avec ce que
j'avais dit tout à l'heure des
opérations de mémoire concernant les
quartiers le bâtier leurs habitants quoi
quel est votre avis monsieur le
rapporteurion a donné un avis favorable
même très favorable puisqu'il s'agit
d'aller dans le sens de la
coconstruction je mets au voix cet
amendement 81 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement est adopté nous en venons à
l'amendement 25 rectifié présenté par
Monsieur vaniren
donc j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir suiv
pour le compte du conseil régional 42
sites en en rue et j'ai remarqué que que
souvent il était pas simple de concilier
deux préoccupations premièrement la
rapidité c'est-à-dire le fait de tenir
un calendrier sans être tenu par les
aléas des contrats successifs et
troisièmement c'est de plus en plus
fondamental tenir euh la performance
énergétique comment le faire et en même
temps en échappant euh parce que j'y
vois plus d'inconvénients que davantage
au
PPP
donc en travaillant sur cette question
avec mon collègue Michel lelb on est
arrivé à la rédaction
de cet amendement qui vise à à permettre
justement au marché intégré c'est-à-dire
ce qu'on appelle les conceptions
réalisation exploitation et maintenance
de pouvoir être reconnu comme des outils
efficaces et performants
socialement
écologiquement au niveau de l'enrue
voilà bien quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur
dy al la commission comprend bien cette
préoccupation qui est je dirais ancienne
à l'Agence nationale de rénovation
urbaine de façon à ce que effectivement
améliorer et et améliorer la la rapidité
des des opérations néanmoins la
Commission se pose des questions d'ordre
juridique elle considère que il y a une
grande insécurité juridique et donc elle
a demandé le retrait ou un avis
défavorable et Monsieur le Ministre quel
est votre avis
oui monsieur le Président euh c'est
effectivement cette cet amendement fait
partie comme l'a dit le rapporteur des
des fois des des préoccupations
anciennes alors je suis mal jugé pour
remplacer puisque je ne suis ministre
que depuis 20 mois de de l'Agence
nationale de rénovation urbaine
néanmoins je dois vous avouer que je
n'ai pas compris
pourquoi et que personne n'a était
encore en capacité de me l'expliquer
puisque le le le crème c'est un une
sorte de contrat de partenariat public
privé bon et que je ne vois pas pourquoi
on emploirait des des PPP pour la
construction et l'entretien d'équipement
public à l'intérieur des quartier de de
rénovation urbaine donc je sais que ça
fait partie peut-être de de de des
usages qui visent estce que à chaque
fois remettre sur l'ouvrage sur le sur
le métier pour qu'au bout d'un moment il
y a un ministre qui accepte mais
personnellement comme je n'ai toujours
pas compris le l'utilité que je vois
même les les dangers
d'une telle méthodologie je prononce un
avit totalement
défavorable je ne vois pas de si Madame
madame lettard pour explication de vote
oui euh monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues juste pour
dire que en ce qui concerne notre groupe
nous sommes du même avis que Monsieur le
Ministre à savoir que c'est vrai que ça
se rapproche très fortement du PPP et
que c'est normalement affecté à de très
gros programmes structurant or
l'investissement dans des équipements en
général sont des équipements plutôt des
équipements publics de proximité des
équipements sociaux mais rarement en
tout cas je connais pas de cas qui
justifierait d'aller vers des montages
aussi complexes aussi lourds qui en
général
relève plutôt d'équipements structurants
suprac commmunaux voire suprac
commmunautaires donc nous étions plutôt
défavorables à moins d'avoir une étude
d'impact qui nous montre la nécessité de
passer à cela mais en l'occurrence on
sait pas
pourquoi je ne vois pas d'autrre demande
d'explication de vote je vais donc
mettre au voix cet amendement 25
rectifié qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté nous en venons
à deux amendements et un sous-amendement
faisant l'objet d'une discussion
commune l'amendement 54 rectifié est
présenté par Madame
benbassard et l'objet de cet amendement
est d'assurer une représentation des
citoyens dans l'une des principales
instances de la politique de la ville
que l'Agence nationale pour la
rénovation urbaine les auteurs du
présent amendement recommande qu'un
tiers du conseil d'administration de
l'enrue soit ouvert à la représentation
associative et
citoyenne j'en viens à l'amendement 16
qui est présenté par Madame
kckerman
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues par cet
amendement simple dont vous nous avez
dit partager l'objectif monsieur le
rapporteur nous souhaitons en tout cas
permettre que des représentants des
associations de locataire puissent
intégrer le conseil d'administration de
l'enrue poser aujourd'hui l'exigence
d'une meilleure association des citoyens
à la politique de la ville impose de
trouver les traductions institutionnel à
ce principe dans ce cadre les
associations de locataires
représentatives temp au niveau national
pardon auraiit toute leur place à ce
conseil de l'enrue qui comporte
aujourd'hui 27 personnes représentant
l'État les collectivités et les
organismes intervenants dans la
politique du logement social il existe
un 4è collège composé de personnes été
qualifié mais qui dans la réalité est
exclusivement composé d'élus nous
proposons donc de réécrire l'article de
la loi de 2003 relative à la politique
de la ville et à la composition du
conseil d'administration de l'enrue en
effet l'article 11 stipule aujourd'hui
que l'Agence nationale pour la
rénovation urbaine est administrée par
un Conseil d'Administration composé en
nombre égal d'une part de représentants
de l'État d'autre part de représentants
des communes de leur établissement
publics de coopération intercommunale
compétent des conseils généraux des
conseils régionaux de l'Union d'économie
sociale du logement de l'Union nationale
des fédérations d'organismes
d'habitation à loyer modérés des
sociétés d'économie mixte de la Caisse
des Dépôts et Consignation de l'Agence
nationale de l'habitat ainsi que de
personnalités qualifiées mais jamais des
représentants des locataires nous
proposons donc d'insérer dans cette
liste la présence de représentants des
associations de locataires afin qu'ils
puissent aussi y siéger une telle
démarche va dans le sens d'une meilleure
prise en compte des besoins des
habitants de ces quartiers par la voie
de leur association représentative et
permettrait également sans aucun doute
d'améliorer l'expertise de l'enrue et
donc l'efficacité de son de son action
pardon pardon donc le sous-amendement
çaarrêreouver et le Gouvernement
présente un sous-amendement
82 à l'amendement numéro
16 peut-être en oui
ou excusez-moi monsieur le prés id oui
effectivement l'amendement prolonge
celui de de présenté par Madame
cuckerman qui effectivement partage
l'avis de sur le fait qu'il faut qu'il y
ait une représentation des des des
locataires voilà cependant l'amendement
impliquerait d'intégrer les
représentants de toutes les associations
de locataires représentatives au niveau
national ce qui ajouterait beaucoup de
membres au conseil d'administration de
de l'anrude qui comporte déjà 36
personnes voilà donc je vous propose
simplement de parler de représ résentant
de de de locataire ça me permet de
peut-être de répondre tout de suite
aussi monsieur le Président si vous
souhaitez à l'amendement de Madame
Benbassa donc je comprends la volonté
mais là nous sommes sur quelque chose
qui est totalement
impossible désigner un un représentant
je l'ai dire excusez-moi cette formule
représentative de l'ensemble des des
habitants des quartiers sur un conseil
d'administration de 36 membres bon me
semble totalement totalement impossible
les règles de de de représentation au
sein du conseil d'administration de
l'anrue ont été codifié moi je ne
souhaite pas qu'on détende le le le CAT
de de lanrue je pense que déjà en ayant
une représentation des associations de
de locataires on répond en partie à
votre à votre questionnement et à votre
à votre volonté mais néanmoins aller
plus loin me semble matériellement
totalement impossible
quoi bien monsieur le rapporteur si vous
pouvez donner votre avis sur l'ensemble
des amendements et sousamendements je
vous confirme madame cuckerman que je
considère que dans dans l'esprit de la
loi il est absolument impensable de de
faire qu'il n'y ait pas de représentant
de locataire dans le conseil
d'administration de l'Agence nationale
de rénovation urbaine en revanche je je
pense que l'amendement de de Madame
mbassa est très compliqué puisque c'est
1/3 donc là ça ça demande un
démantèlement total de l'actuelle
conseil d'administration mais la
Commission a a donné un avis favorable à
l'amendement de Madame kckerman que
madame kuckerman a proposé à condition
que le sous-amendement du gouvernement
soit accepté donc c'est un avis
favorable au sous-amendement et s'il est
voté favorable à l'amendement de Madame
cuckerman bien
donc retirer l'amendement 54 rectifié et
retiré je mets donc au voix le le
sous-amendement 82 présenté
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient donc le
sousamendement est adopté je mets donc
au voit l'amendement 16 ainsi rectifié
même vote je suppose l'amendement est
par
adopté nous en venons à l'amendement 15
rectifié qui est présenté par
madameur
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues donc cet
amendement pose un principe simple le
financement de l'enrue doit relever
principalement de la solidarité
nationale et donc du budget de l'État
ainsi il faut se rappeler
qu'initialement la loi du 1er août 2003
avait posé le principe d'un financement
paritaire de l'enrue par l'État et le 1
% logement cependant comme le souligne
le rapport sur ce projet de loi l'État
c'est depuis désengagés notamment avec
la loi du 25 mars 2009 dit loi molle qui
a conduit à faire reposer quasi
entièrement le financement de l'enrue
par Action Logement aujourd'hui le 1 %
assure en effet 800 millions d'euros à
l'enrue chaque année ce retrait de
l'État conduit à une externalisation du
du financement de la politique de
logement nous contestons la
multiplication des des missions d'Action
Logement et cela nous inquiète euh le 1%
logement et mise à contribution donc
pour la rénovation urbaine pour le
financement des aides des aPL pour les
aides à la pierre et bientôt vous le
savez la garantie universelle des loyers
par C par cet amendement il s'agit donc
de rappeler à l'état ses obligations en
matière de financement de la politique
de la ville cet amendement reprend en
réalité l'article 17 de la proposition
de loi déposée en mars 2011 par le
groupe socialiste à l'Assemblée
nationale et vous le savez par vous-même
monsieur le ministre nous espérons
espérons qu'au moins sur les principes
nous pourrons nous retrouver je rappelle
ici que l'adoption de cet amendement ne
metta ne mettrait nullement en péril les
ressources actuelles de l'enrue comme on
l'a tenté de nous le faire croire mais
permettrait simplement d'affirmer le
principe qui resterait à traduire dans
le cadre des prochaines lois de
finances quel est l'AVE de la commission
oui la commission déplore effectivement
le retrait de l'État depuis de
nombreuses années et souhaite le retour
de l'État mais aujourd'hui il paraît
difficile de de faire passer cet
amendement contrairement à ce que vous
dites je je crains que on abandonne des
financements garantis je vais pas
reprendre la formule du ministre je vais
lui laisser le soin de la redire mais je
je je crains qu'on abandonne des
financements garantis au bénéfice mais
je mets beaucoup de guillemets à
bénéfice de financements qui sont loin
d'être garanti donc c'est un avis
défavorable enfin un retrait ou un avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre
oui
madame je va pas revenir sur ce que j'ai
pu dire tout à l'heure sur ma définition
du socialisme du
communisme
néanmoins
pardon oui tout à
fait voilà bon mais néanmoins il y a
effectivement un cocktail de financement
de la rénovation urbine o l'état apporte
sa part puisque il y a voilà il y a une
taxe sur les plusvalues de session
immobilières élevé en partie affecté à
lanrue depuis depuis la fin la la la fin
2012 bon moi ce qui me semble important
compte tenu du du contexte après tout si
nous avons un accord avec Action
Logement sur le financement de la
rénovation urbaine après tout je veux
dire moi je n'ai pas de de de des accord
et si effectivement les les capacités
d'État peuvent être redéployé sur
d'autres budgets je ne vois pas là aussi
où il peut y avoir de de difficultés
l'important c'est qu'on puisse avoir un
financement qui soit soutenu du d'une
part du du premier plan de rénovation
urbaine ce qui est le cas bon même si ça
n'a pas pris le rythme que d'cun souité
mais là encore je je vous ai rappelé
tout à l'heure les difficultés les
contraintes par rapport à un plan de de
telle ampleur et l'important c'est que
soit sécurisé surtout le nouveau plan de
de renouvellement urbain ce que je vous
confirmeoi bien donc
je mets au voix C am ah Monsieur Dalier
souhaite intervenir auparavant pour
explication de vote oui monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues c'est vrai qu'en son
temps comme rapporteur spécial j'avais
aussi regretté le désendettement de
l'État qui à l'époque avait été fort
critiqué sur les bancs de ce quiétait
l'opposition bon aujourd'hui tout le
monde s'en accommode j'ai envie de vous
dire voilà on est bien obligé la
situation budgétaire de l'État est- ce
qu'elle est et à mon avis il serait
assez illusoire de compter sur euh de
nouveaux crédits euh directs et
budgétaires donc l'important c'est ce
que je disais à l'époque et je le redis
ce soir c'est qu'effectivement nous
ayons la certitude qu'au bout du compte
l'agence trouve les financements dont
elle a besoin et c'est pourquoi il faut
vraiment surveiller sa trésorerie euh
jean-germain a tout à fait raison il ne
faut pas la laisser descendre trop bas
sinon les délais de paiement s'allongent
et ce sont les collectivité local les
sociétés d'économie mixte qui en qui en
pâtissent donc c'est vraiment là que
nous vons porter toute notre attention
ceci étant dit pour aller un tout petit
peu plus loin le financement de l'enrue
était problématique mais il y avait
aussi le financement de laana et ça fait
un moment qu'on en a pas parlé dans cet
hémicycle et l'Agence Nationale pour
l'Amélioration de l'Habitat intervient à
priori dans tous les quartiers et
celui-là de financement il n'est plus
garanti du tout parce qu'il y avait à
l'origine également des crédits
budgétaires qui ont disparu je crois de
mémoire que Action Logement il
contribuait aussi c'est fini et
aujourd'hui théoriquement le financement
de l'ANA doit être fait au travers de la
revente des fameux certificats euh voilà
qui carbone qui ne donne pas du tout ce
qu'il devait donner et laana va se
trouver en difficulté donc financement
de l' rue financement de l'ANA c'est
vrai qu'il y a deux sujets importants en
tous les cas dans tous les territoires
concernés par la politique de la ville
il faudra que en prochaine loi de
finance ou dans un texte à venir sur le
logement nous reposions ces sujets
bien je mets cette fois au voix cet
amendement 15 rectifié qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté je mets maintenant au voix
l'article 2 ainsi amendé qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'article 2 est
adopté article 2 B même vote même vote
il est adopté l'article 3 est supprimé
et nous en arrivons à l'article 4 avec
une demande de parole de Monsieur
Christian Favier
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet article
donc 4 porte sur la géographie
prioritaire je voudrais
simplement rappeler notre regret
monsieur le ministre pour les
parlementaires de ne pas disposer donc
de la liste des quartier prioritaire il
s'agit évidemment d' d'un élément
d'information qui était pour nous à nos
yeux évidemment important et un élément
de confiance vis-à-vis de ce projet de
loi le présent article se contente en
effet uniquement de définir donc un
critère de zonage unique devant
permettre la définition des futurs
quartiers prioritaires en remplacement
des anciennes zones urbaines sensibles
nous l'avons déjà dit le choix du
critère unique comme unique est un
progrès et donc nous nous en félicitons
il introduit il y aura plus de justice
et de lisibilité dans le dispositif en
permettant donc de concentrer les aides
sur les quartiers qui en ont le plus
besoin pour pour autant le choix donc du
critère unique ne masque pas au fond la
volonté aussi gouvernementale de rester
pour l'instant à budget constant et pour
l'avenir de limiter les territoires
d'intervention de l'État au travers donc
de la politique de la ville en effet peu
importe les modalités retenues la
conclusion déjà posée par le
gouvernement le nombre de quartiers
prioritaire par on le sait de 2400 à
1300 et c'està direire que la situation
donc pour 1100 quartiers auparavant
bénéficiire d'uncux serait donc ce
serait à ce point donc amélioré et donc
n'aurait donc plus besoin donc d'être
accompagné si nous pouvons convenir
évidemment qu'un certain nombre de
quartiers devaient sortir de la
géographie
prioritaire le fait que celle-ci soit
divisée pratiquement par deux évidemment
nous qute vous dites qu'il y aura pour
cela pour ceux qui ne seront plus donc
Jux prioritaires la possibilité
évidemment d'accéder au au droits commun
c'est en effet évidemment une évidence
he la politique de la ville ne peut pas
à elle seule évidemment apporter toutes
les réponses aux difficultés sociales
rencontrées au sein des quartiers
populaires qui répondent donc à des
difficultés profondes euh mais dans ce
cadre il faut reconnaître que les choix
gouvernementaux notamment aujourd'hui en
matière budgétaire peuvent être lourd de
conséquences notamment bon on l'a dit et
répété les dotations au
collectivité vont diminuer diminu dors
et déjà depuis le début de cette année
de 4 milliards et demi sur 3 ans pour
les collectivité local et l'objectif
reste évidemment celui donc de couper
dans les dépenses de servicees publics
au nom donc de la rigueur et c'est le
cas malheureusement aussi on le sait
dans en matière par exemple de santé de
transport notamment vous aurez donc des
difficultés on le voit à mettre en œuvre
ces moyens de droit commun et les
collectivités elles-mêmes auront du mal
évidemment à compenser ce désengagement
ou cette réduction évidemment de
l'intervention de l'État au titre du
droit commun euh donc sur cette base-l
évidemment c'est nous voulions
évidemment attirer votre attention sur
cette question il est évident que les
déclarations du président de la
République cet après-midi
malheureusement ne font que renforcer
évidemment notre inquiétude par rapport
à
cela je vais donc mettre au voie
l'article 4 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'article 4 est adopté à l'article 5
j'ai une demande de parole de Madame
cherche
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues article
traite de la contractualisation de la
politique de la ville entre l'État et
les collectivités les actuels CUCS
deviendront des contrats de ville et
leurs modalités de conclusion seront
donc largement revues avec un périmètre
étréc comme vient de le dire mon
collègue Christian Favier cela pose la
question de la sortie du dispositif
contractuel mais nous y reviendrons à
l'article 9 bis pour justement renforcer
la veille active de ces territoires nous
adhérons à la volonté au travers de ces
contrats de mobiliser prioritairement
les moyens de droit commun car la
politique de la ville reste
fondamentalement une politique
corrective qui n'a de porté que dans le
casadre d'un droit commun suffisant
cette intégration du droit commun dans
les contrats de ville permettra
également plus de transparence et de
lisibilité sur l'effort réellement
consenti par ailleurs vous définissez
l'échelon de contractualisation au
niveau intercommunal et donc ce qui
induit des transferts de compétences si
ces transferts sont effectivement
aujourd'hui une réalité demain plus
encore dans le cadre des lois de
décentralisation comme de la loi
logement nous sommes inquiets des
répercussions en terme de démocratie de
cette démarche de dévitalisation des
communes au profit des intercommunalités
alors même que le rôle de proximité des
élus locaux n'est plus à démontrer pour
cela nous avons donc proposé dès la
commission d'acter que le maire reste
responsable sur le territoire de sa
commune et dans le cadre de ses
compétences le maître d'œuvre du contrat
de ville cet amendement a été adopté et
nous estimons qu'il améliore de manière
sensible cet
article la politique de la ville est une
politique de précision qui nécessite une
connaissance fine du du territoire et
une proximité forte avec la population
cela nécessite à nos yeux non de
renforcer les transferts de compétences
et l'éloignement des prises de décision
mais de travailler comme vous l'avez
d'ailleurs écrit à la coconstruction
avec les habitants bien sûr mais aussi
avec l'ensemble des élus concernés par
un territoire et ce de l'élaboration du
diagnostic à la mise en œuvre du contrat
de ville et nous serons à ce titre très
attentif à l'association de la
population des quartiers concernés cet
aspect est une amélioration majeure par
rapport à l'existant mais il faudra
monsieur le ministre donner les moyens y
compris humains et financiers pour faire
vivre ces instances de démocratie
participative
qui présente l'amendement 17 c'est
Madame
cuckerman
excusez-moi monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous entrons bien évidemment à travers
cet amendement sur le travail sur
l'article donc cela rejoint les propos
que viennent de de tenir ma collègue mir
chch puisque à travers ce premier
amendement nous souhaitons supprimer met
les mots à l'échelle intercommunale afin
de lever une ambiguïé liée à la
rédaction de ce projet de loi nous avons
bien compris que vous souhaitiez
monsieur le ministre affirmer que
l'échelon pertinent pour la conclusion
des nouveaux contrats de ville était cet
échelon intercommunal pour autant la
rédaction actuelle de ce projet de loi
reste au milieu du gay vous contraignez
en effet la conclusion des contrats de
ville à l'échelle intercommunale sans
pour autantire une compétence
obligatoire pour ces mêmes
intercommunalités il semble ainsi
difficile de contraindre des
intercommunalités qui ne disposeraient
pas de compétences politiques de la
ville à être signataire de contrat de
ville que se passera-t-il d'ailleurs si
certaines intercommunalités refusent
d'être signatairees vous aviez
effectivement prévu une sanction
pécuniaire
initialement nous avons obtenu en
commission sa suppression puisque elle
semblait injuste et inefficace de fait à
à partir du moment où il ne s'agit pas
d'une compétence obligatoire des EPCI il
n'y a alors à nos yeux aucune légitimité
juridique ni même politique à imposer ce
périmètre intercommunal pour la
conclusion de ces contrats de ville vous
aurez donc compris que nous ne
contestons pas la pertinence de cette
échelle intercommunale tel que le
proposé par principe mais simplement
l'automaticité de cette échelle sur le
fond nous considérons que la bonne
démarche est celle du respect de la
volonté des collectivités concerné et de
laisser le temps de la construction
de plus les problématiques soulevées par
un contrat de ville sont par définition
denses complexes puisqu'elles touch
d'abord à l'humain les maires de par
leur rôle de proximité sont alors un
maillon essentiel de tout contrat de
ville c'est la vision que nous portons
nous estimons donc inefficace de
contraindre que ce contrat de ville soit
systématiquement conclu à l'échelle
intercommunale nous estimons nécessaire
au contraire de garantir une certaine
souplesse ce que pourrait permettre
notre
amendement avis de la commission
monsieur lin monsieur le président la
commission a donné un avis défavorable
évidemment à cet amendement d'abord
parce que nous pensons que l'échelle
intercommunale est obligatoirement la
bonne échelle je je l'ai dit dans mon
intervention il n'est pas acceptable que
des quartiers soient considérés comme
prioritaires et appel à la solidarité
nationale c'estàd à la solidarité de
tous alors que par égoïsme certaines
communalités refusent de les euh
considéré comme quartier prioritaire et
ne font pas jouer la la prior la
priorité et la péréquation
intercommunale donc c'est une première
réponse la deuxième réponse madame chch
l'a dit dans son intervention je crois
que ce qui est intéressant dans ce texte
de loi c'est qu'il y a une très bonne
articulation entre le niveau
intercommunal et le maire et
effectivement la commission a adopté un
amendement proposé par Madame Church qui
permet encore un peu plus de rassurer
les le le maire sur sa sa maîtrise
d'œuvre euh de ces euh de ces programmes
donc le la commission pense que il faut
impérativement que ces euh contrats
soient signés à à l'échelle
intercommunale donc retrait ou avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président je je partage
totalement la la l'avis du rapporteur et
je Seris tenté de dire j'ai écouté vos
propos madameaman en me disant que le
gouvernement était au milieu du gay
j'aurais plusut tendance à vous vous
renvoyer la la formule voilà c'est vrai
que je sais que historiquement entre la
commune
l'intercommunalité petit à petit l'idée
fait son chemin dans dans dans vos rangs
voilà ici nous sommes arrivés à un bon
compromis nul n'imagine que on puisse
penser entre autres les les opérations
de désenclavement des quartiers par les
transports en commun uniquement à les
Chel communal bon et donc on pourrait
pas se satisfaire et je pense à quelques
quelques collectivités entre autres tout
seigneur tout honneur à à la
collectivité qui a dirigé euh Claude
dyin je veux dire on sait bien les
problèmes de d'enclavement de clichis
sous bois bon et on sait bien aussi
pourquoi ils ont eu tant de mal à se
régler par manque de
solidarité de la faute des collectivités
qui était environnante bon donc le fait
que on se situe bien maintenant avec
dans un bon compromis du territoire
intercommunal qui a défin les le le
diagnostic les axes stratégiques les
politiques de désenclavement de
développement économique et d'autre part
le le le le maire maître d'œuvre des
politiques de cohésion sociale et de
rénovation urbaine sur son secteur on a
le le le bon équilibre mais votre
amendement aboutira à la situation
actuelle à savoir que vous n'avez que
quatre intercommunalités sur 10 qui sont
actuellement partie prenante de la
politique de la ville alors moi mon
objectif c'est qu'on soit à 100 % et on
aura l'occasion de reparler d'ailleurs
aussi en ce qui concerne les
départements et les région parce que
nous sommes à peu près dans le même
rapport voir même un peu moins puisqu'on
est à un/ers des régions un/ers des
départements et qu'il faut maintenant
que la solidarité vis-à-vis de de ces
quartiers et des villes qui comportent
des quartiers prioritaires soit total
vertical mais aussi horizontal donc un
avis totalement défavorable donc je vous
en demande le retrait madame cuckerman
pour explication de datote je crois que
au vu effectivement bon des arguments du
fait effectivement vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le rapporteur que nous avons
obtenu en commission un certain nombre
de de garanties sur le la place du du
maire dans dans dans l'élaboration du du
contrat de ville et sur sa maîtrise et
puis effectivement je crois monsieur le
ministre mais sur tous les bancs le
rapport et la place des communes et de
l'intercommunalité évolue toujours dans
le sens en tout cas de répondre aux
besoins des populations des territoires
concernés puis je crois que comme les
matchs de tennis actuellement se font de
l'autre côté de la planète effectivement
nous allons retirer notre amendement
pour cette soirée bien donc l'amendement
17 est retiré nous en venons à
l'amendement 39 rectifié qui est bis qui
est présenté par Monsieur Mirassou
peut-être merci monsieur le Président
cet amendement vise engager par le biais
de leur signature respective les
départements et les régions dans les
nouveaux contrats de ville en effet j'ai
l'occasion de l'évoquer tout à l'heure
eu égard compétences qui sont les leurs
pour les uns en matière sociale et
solidarité pour les autres en terme de
développement économique de formation
professionnel transport les conseils
généraux et régionaux à l'évidence sont
des partenaires naturels des communes et
des EPCI c'est la raison pour laquelle
elles doivent nécessairement être
impliquées dans la mobilisation des
politiques de droit commun et c'est du
reste tout l'enjeu de ce projet de loi
cette mobilisation conditionne la
réussite de la prochaine génération de
contrat de ville et par ailleurs il y a
une forme de cohérence puisque l'ADF et
la RF ont signé en 2013 avec vous
monsieur le ministre des conventions
cadres pour s'investir plus avant dans
les prochains contrats de ville avec
notamment la mobilisation des fonds
structurels européens FSE fé
quel est l'avis de la
commission la Commission donne un avis
favorable même si elle a bien conscience
que c'est une petite révolution mais
effectivement il est paraît difficile
d'imaginer toujours dans l'esprit de de
ce texte que les collectivités
territoriales comme les régions ou les
départements restent à l'écart de de ce
contrat donc la la commission a donné un
avis favorable monsieur le
ministre
oui monsieur le Président je suis à je
suis ennuyé par par votre amendement
parce que je partage totalement et le
Gouvernement partage totalement le le
fond de cet amendement c'est d'ailleurs
pour cela que comme je viens de le dire
moi je souhaite que l'ensemble des des
départements et des régions soit
signataire et s'engage à l'intérieur des
contrats ville à la fois sur les actions
de cohésion sociale mais aussi sur les
opérations de de rénovation urbaine
c'est dans ce sens d'ailleurs que j'ai
signé assez rapid rement une convention
avec l'Association des régions de France
et au moment de leur congrès avec
l'Association des départements de France
voilà néanmoins il y a la constitution
et la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales voilà donc
et oui et oui monsieur le sénateur c'est
pas ici dans cette maison que que je que
je vais être obligé de le de le rappeler
voilà donc je dirais que je suis
conscient que c'est une bataille
politique même si enfin les les
fondamentaux ont été engagés par par le
gouvernement à travers la signature de
ces conventions j'ai conscience que que
les régions et les départements ont à
cœur de de de s'engager dans la
politique de la ville y compris par le
fait de la réservation de au moins 10 %
des des fonds européens dont ils auront
la charge vers les quartiers
prioritaires de la politique de la ville
mais le gouvernement néanmoins ne peut
pas accepter un amendement qui irait à
l'encontre de la Constitution et donc je
vous demande de le retirer ou sinon ça
sera un avis
défavorable bien une demande
d'explication de vot de la part de
Monsieur
Foucher simplement monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président je connais bien
les problèmes des départements comme
Monsieur Mirassou mais est-ce que c'est
pas une forme aussi de désengagement de
l'État sur ces contrat et deuxièmement
on parle de plus en plus de
clarification des compétences le
président de la République aussi le dit
clarification des compétences certaines
compétences au régions d'autres au
départements mais là c'est tout à fait
le contraire on définitive on continue à
à avoir des compétences communes pour
pour tout le mondei ça me paraît un peu
contraire
à à ce qui est dit
aujourd'hui monsieur Favier pour
explication de vote oui monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre bon pour
notre part nous nous partageons
évidemment l'objectif de faire en sorte
que le maximum de départements et le
maximum de régions puisse être partie
prenante de la mise en œuvre de la de
cette politique de la ville et par
exemple pour mon propre département par
par exemple concernant l' rue nous avons
à l'époque signé et nous sommes engagés
financièrement à une hauteur importante
pour accompagner cette politique de
renouvellement urbain pour autant je
pense que ça doit rester effectivement
une décision souveraine des assemblées
élues qu'elle soit régionale ou
départemental et que ça ne peut ça ne
peut pas je dirais être à caractère
obligatoire de par la loi je pense qu'il
faut que ça puisse rester effectivement
une décision qui doit être prise par par
par ces assemblées je pense que il faut
respecter effectivement cette libre
administration des
collectivités monsieur le rapporteur
vous souhaitez intervenir à ce stade je
voudrais juste préciser à Monsieur
Foucher qu'il y a pas d'incompatibilité
parce que le département peut signer un
contrat de ville dans le cadre de ses
compétences il s'agit pas il s'agit pas
d'intervenir hors de ses compétences
obligatoires par exemple le département
sur les collèges c'est quand même
important dans ses quartiers ou sur
l'aide sociale c'est quand même
important sur S quartiers peut
redéployer ses moyens tout à fait de
droit commun mais dans le cadre de ses
compétences obligatoires au bénéfice de
ces quartiers c'est ça que ça veut dire
on lui demande pas d'avoir forcément des
lignes spécifiques politiques de la
ville madame lettard vous souhaitez
intervenir pour explication de vote
oui monsieur le Président chers
collègues mais monsieur dylain m'a
devancer parce que je voudrais je
voulais dire tout simplement la même
chose à savoir que sans revenir sur la
libre administration des collectivité
c'est vrai que les conseils généraux
comme les régions sont compétents dans
nombre de domaines qui intéressent la
politique de la ville au même titre
qu'on demande aux intercommunalités de
ne pas s'exonérer d'un partenariat avec
les communes sur la mise en œuvre de la
politique de la ville hein et au
contraire de faire marcher et faire
fonctionner la solidarité communautaire
dans le champ de ses compétences et dans
le cadre des missions de coordination et
d'animation fixé par la loi il nous
paraît quand même absolument déterminant
et et et et et indispensable au bon
fonctionnement de la politique de la
ville que ni département ni région ne
s'exonèr d'appliquer leur champ de
compétence sur des territoires de
politique de la ville où on a plus que
jamais besoin qu'ils interviennent sur
leur politique de droit commun et que
s'ils le souhaite et c'est là la libre
administration des départements venir
conforter et amplifier leur intervention
donc ça me paraît plutôt judicieux qu'il
puisse intervenir dans ce sens monsieur
Mirassou écoutez moi je conçois
l'argumentation de monsieur le ministre
qui qui me reprocherait en quelque sorte
moi et le groupe que je représente de
vouloir malgré eux le le bonheur des
régions et et des départements à ce si
près que dès l'instant où par rapport à
ce projet de loi on en appelle dans le
sens positif au plus grand nombre
s'agissant de l'engagement citoyen qui a
fait l'objet tout à l'heure de beaucoup
de débats il serait quand même paradoxal
que l'engagement citoyen vaille pour le
simple citoyen mais ne vaille pas pour
ceux qui sont censés les représenter je
veux parler des régions et des
départements alors je vais pas faire une
fixation
sur peuvent ou doivent on doit pouvoir
se trouver un moyen terme intéressant
mais je retiens quand même ce qu'on dit
et exposé tout à l'heureve beaucoup de
de de lucidité en ce qui concerne le
rapporteur et Valérie lard quand un
département choisit délébèement à
travers la politique scolaire qui est la
sienne de favoriser la présence même
quand ça va mal et surtout quand ça va
mal du service public de proximité
notamment les collèges et bien c'est une
démonstration suffisante qu le même
département à travers des installations
favorise la politique sportive ou pour
le coup l'insertion sociale prend le pas
sur la politique sportive elle-même et
bien il fait délibérément le choix de
faire de la politique de la ville donc
écoutez si on doit pouvoir d'une manière
très encourageante dire départements et
régions doivent pouvoir ou peuvent on va
en parler une affaire d'état et au bout
du bout c'est l'engagement des HS et des
autres qui dira qui a
raison est-ce que cette formulation vous
convient monsieur le ministre c'est
quand je dis ça j'interpelle le Conseil
constitutionnel par ministre interposé
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a toujours
le Conseil constitutionnel les Bac + 15
là on laisse peut-être s'exprimer
monsieur Viren donc avant le président
Raoul peut-être non non vous souhaitez
intervenir vous souhaitez intervenir bon
monsieur monie vir donc je vous en prie
ma voix quand je parle avant le
président Raoul
euh mais dire la chose suivante quand il
s'est agi dans la génération précédente
de
lanrue de demander 1 € à la région
nordpcalais à chaque fois que en rue et
éat en mettait trois je vous assure
qu'il y a personne à l'état à n'importe
quel étage qui est venu me parler du
principe de de la libre administration
hein hein personne he personne euh
donc soyons prêt à faire quelques
amendements peut-être sur les temps des
conjugaisons mais gardons ce principe
sacroin qui est
qu'effectivement en terme de solidarité
territoriale de cohésion sociale le
département est nécessairement
interpellé et la région l' à plus d'un
titre également et elle le sera encore
plus le peu que j'ai pu comprendre endre
de la conférence de presse de du
président de la République de cet
après-midi
donc plus le contrat est multilatéral
plus les gens mobilisent et adaptent
leurs droits commun plus cette politique
a des chances véritablement de marquer
des
points bien monsieur monsieur le
Président vous si vous voulez bien vous
exprimer je voudrais simplement
intervenir sur suite à la déclaration de
de Monsieur monsieur le ministre vous
venez de dire monsieur le ministre que
10 % des crédits européens des fonds FSE
serait affecté à la politique de la
ville j'ai bien compris au quartiers
prioritaires et cetera c'était un des
critères d'utilisation de ces fonds mais
si j'ai bien compris aussi la logique
qui est en train de s'instaurer en tous
les cas une revendication de la part des
régions de gérer ses fonds alors comment
ces contrat de ville ne serait pas signé
en même temps qu'on utiliserait les
fonds européens qui seraient gérés par
les là il y a quelque chose je veux bien
toutes les subtilités constitutionnelles
qu'on veut mais dans la formulation de
notre collègue jean-Jacques Mirassou si
on mettait peuvent être signés dans la
mesure où il y aurait
des alors le doiv c'est vrai que pose un
problème je suis d'accord on peut pas
contraindre au niveau des collectivités
mais quand même dans la mesure où les
régions revendiquent la gestion des
fonds européens ils doivent s'impliquer
dans les
contratuille bien monsieur le
ministre si vous
souhaitez
compléter ce débat compliqué je partage
totalement la vie du président raou de
Monsieur Mirassou de Monsieur V direndon
bien entendu c'est pour ça je vous dis
que j'ai j'ai signé ces conventions et
compris sur le fait que les je pense que
toutes les régions et tous les
départements puisquon en est
actuellement plutôt à un/ers des
départements un des qui sign les
contrats urbain de cohésion sociale
c'est à peu près le le le le pourcentage
je pense que tous doivent s'engager
toutes les collectivité et sur leurs
compétences d'ailleurs sur les dans la
convention que j'ai signé avec
l'Association des départements de France
on s'est fixé deux objectifs plus
particulier mais qui dépendent de la
compétence des départements à savoir le
soutien et l'accompagnement des familles
monoparentales les un sujet qui n'est
rarement voir jamais abordé pour les
quartiers populaires à savoir la
question des retraités nous n'avons eu
aucun programme spécifique actuellement
ni nationalement ni même localement
vis-à-vis des retraités des des
quartiers populaires alors que nous
sommes sur des quartiers qui sont
débordants de jeunesse pu qui
vieillissent en même temps voilà mais
néanmoins je je voilà je suis je ne peux
qu'en appeler qu'à la sagesse de de
cette noble maison qui par ailleurs et
la représentation aussi des collectivité
territorial la constitution de mon point
de vue du point de vue du gouvernement
ne permet pas d'obliger un département
ou une région à signer un
contrat un contrat de de ville même si
je je pense que tous doivent le faire
voilà bien je vais donc mettre au voit
cet amendement 39 rectifié bis qui est
pour 2 3 4
5 qui est
contre qui
s'abstient donc l'amendement est adopté
nous en venons au 68 rectifié qui est
présenté par Monsieur
daliier Merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise à poser le problème
de la future métropole du Grand Paris et
de la signature de ces fameux contrat de
ville alors je ne prétends pas que
l'amendement qui est proposé ici dans sa
rédaction soit parfait ni même forcément
bien placé dans l'article puisque je
proposais d'insérer une disposition
après l'alinéa 1 mais enfin faute de
d'amendement qu'est-ce que je peux
trouver dans cet article qui pourrait se
référer à la métropole ou qui serait
applicable à la métropole du Grand Paris
à l'alinéa 5 je lis sur le territoire
intercommunal l'établissement public de
coopération intercommunale compétent
enfin compétent on se demande ce qu'
vient de faire là d'ailleurs en matière
de politique de la ville est chargé du
diagnostic du territoire de la
définition désorientation de l'animation
et de la coordination du contrat de
ville la métropole du Grand Paris sera
le PCI donc j'en conclurai à la lecture
de cet alinéa que c'est la métropole du
Grand Paris qui sera chargé
effectivement du diagnostic des
orientations de l'animation et de la
coordination de chacun des contrats de
villes signé sur le territoire de la
métropole à l'échelle de 7 millions
d'habitants euh ça me semble peut-être
un compliqué si je vais ensuite à
laalinéa 9 jeie qu'en Île-de-France le
représentant de l'État dans la région
peut proposer des contrats de ville sur
des périmètres différents de ceux des
établissements publics de coopération
intercommunale donc là on est plutôt
dans euh la liberté la plus total donné
au préfet qui pourrait dans l'espace de
la métropole choisir lui-même
effectivement de choisir un périmètre
communal intercommunal enfin en dehors
même des conseils de territoire les
choses sont assez floues si on s'en
tient à la rédaction actuelle alors mon
amendement est presque un amendement
d'appel monsieur le ministre mais je
pense qu'il faut que vous précisiez la
position du gouvernement moi j'ai plutôt
tendance à considérer que dans ce
périmètre de la métropole du grandpis où
toutes les communes ont quand même une
taille moyenne relativement importante
et où elles sont toutes en tous les cas
celles qui sont concernées engagé de
longues dates dans la politique de la
ville est-ce que malgré tout la commune
ne reste pas à quelques exceptions près
j'allais dire le bon
interlocuteur même pour le le travail de
diagnostic et de dentelle après il y a
le problème du financement mais en tous
les cas pour effectuer ce travail est-ce
que la commune ne reste pas le meilleur
interlocuteur ça peut être
l'intercommunalité mais sur une base qui
a mon sens n'est pas forcément celle du
conseil de territoire parce qu'en sain
saint-is on va avoir trois ou quatre
conseils de territoire c'est-à-dire des
plaques de 400 500000 habitants est-ce
que c'est la bol échelle pour faire ce
travail de dentelle honnêtement je n'en
suis pas certain alors je n'ai pas une
rédaction parfaite loin de là mais je
pense qu'il faut creuser le sujet et je
souhaitais vous entendre sur
celui-ci monsieur le rapporteur qu est
l'avis de la commission
oui alors d'abord peut-être une
rectification parce que sur le la
métropole du Grand Paris la politique de
la ville est dans la loi la seule
compétence qui est remontée qui
redescend au conseil de territoire donc
c'est c'est clair c'est dans la loi
c'est la seule compétence qui a fait le
yoyo comme on disait dans la loi c'était
un amendement que j'ai déposé qui a été
voté ici même donc de toute façon ça ça
concerne plus du tout la métropole du
Grand Paris parce que vous avez raison 6
million et demi faire un contrat de
ville ça me paraît impensable c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
j'avais demandé à ce que ça retombe
automatiquement dans le conseil de
territoire maintenant la deuxième
question est-ce que le conseil de
territoire est l'échelle la plus
pertinente je crois que comme vous on
peut se poser des des questions et je
crois que le ministre y a fait allusion
tout à l'heure et et et je crois qu'il
va y refaire allusion parce que le
gouvernement va présenter l'amendement
44 qui devrait régler ce ce problème
donc ce que je vous conseille vous avez
fait un amendement d'appel qui me paraît
d'ailleurs tout à fait légitime une fois
que le ministre vous a répondu peut-être
retirer votre amendement au quel cas il
y aurait sinon il y aurait un avis
défavorable bien
sûr monsieur le ministre quel est votre
avis sur cet amendement 68 rectifié oui
comme vous l'avez dit Monsieur il est
pas il est pas parfait mais né moins
c'est intéressant d'avoir le d'avoir le
débat comme on l'a déjà pu l'avoir tout
tout à l'heure là-dessus bon nous sommes
en train de de travailler parallèlement
avec l'avancement de la loi métropole
bon effectivement la métropole n'est pas
pas le bon horizon et le bon pour tour
pour pour élaborer la politique de la
ville comme l'a rappelé le le rapporteur
c'est plutôt au niveau des conseils de
territoire que que devra se se déléguer
la la compétence quand vous dites que
c'est pas le le bon niveau à 3 ou 400000
habitants faisons
attention prenons l'agglomération
lyonnaise et puis on chiffre en tête le
le voilà on doit êre à plus d'un million
effectivement d'habitants au sein de
l'agglomération
lyonnaise la politique de la ville et de
compétten intercommunal intercommunal et
ça se passe très bien parce que c'est
dans cette agglomération qu'on a été en
capacité de dessiner un schéma de
transport qui soit totalement cohérent
avec une seule autorité de de de
transport c'est là qu'on a pu iser des
politiques de peuplement qui se fassent
à l'échelle de de l'intercommunalité
c'est là qu'on a pu aussi avoir une
politique assez offensive en matière
d'équipement public et de rénovation
urbaine avec des établissements de
création et diffusion culturelle sur
quasiment l'ensemble des des des grandes
communes de cette intercommunalité donc
c'est le bon échelon bon après ça ne
préjuge pas du fait que bien entendu
comme on a pu le dire le maire est
toujours l'opérateur de de proximité je
vous invite vraiment à voir ce qui se
passe dans l'agglomération lyonnaise que
je cite S vent en exemple parce que cela
montre qu'on peut avoir à des niveaux
aussi
importants la capacité de pouvoir faire
de la bonne politique de la ville mais
si on redescend à l'échelle communale
alors je connais les résultats en région
de France voilà c'est je suis même pas
certain qu'on aura ADV vitam etnam
clichier Montfermeil on aura même
peut-être est-ce qu'on peut imaginer que
finalement par le la voix du fait
que d'autres communes refuserait que ça
se passe à l'échelle intercommunale que
tout d'un coup une commune comme
clichine commune comme une commune comme
monfermeil quand même jeis en prendre
une autre une commune comme Sevran
pourrait se retrouver seul à gérer ses
problèmes de politique de la ville je
crois que c'est pas pensable voilà donc
moi je je pense qu'il faut qu'on en
reste à à à la à la proposition actuelle
que là où il y a des métropoles qui sont
à qui sont dans dans la loi et donc je
pense tout particulièrement à la région
in defance ou à celle de Marse conse on
en reste au conseil de territoire mais
que néanmoins le préfet puisse choisir
parce qu'il peut y avoir des
spécificités il peut y avoir des
spécificités qui permettent au préfet et
en général les préfets ne le font pas
d'autorité ils le font en collaboration
avec avec les élus de choisir des
périmètres qui soient un peu différents
ou totalement différents tenant compte
des des contraintes physiques des fois
même des contraintes politiques ce qui
peut arriver dans voilà dans nos
collectivités
quoi mon monsieur Dalier pour
explication de vote monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le ministre votre comparaison entre le
conseil de territoire à 3 4 ou 500000
habitants dans le Grand Paris et la
métropole de Lyon ne vaut pas
elle est pas pertinente c'est justement
parce que je n'ai jamais voulu je n'ai
jamais pensé que découper la scène
Saint- NIS en quatre ou cinq plaque
d'Interco nous aiderait à régler nos
problèmes que depuis 2007 et 2008 je
plaide pour la métropole du Grand Paris
donc ne faites pas cette comparaison là
parce qu'effectivement que ça soit en
matière de transport ou en matière de
politique de peuplement bien évidemment
que c'est sur l'échelle métropolitaine
qu'il faut raisonner et certainement pas
à l'échelle des conseils de territoire
parce que couper Classen saint en 4 ou 5
vous n'aurez rien changé il faut
réfléchir à une échelle plus large et
c'est pour ça que je dis que
l'organisation doit être adapté au
territoire si particulier de cette
métropole du Grand Paris c'est là où la
où effectivement il faut inventer
quelque chose de particulier alors
effectivement on redescend au conseil de
territoire bon euh moi je persiste après
tout aussi également tout dépend de quoi
on parle bien évidemment que si on parle
des financements il est pas question de
laisser les communes toutes seulle si on
parle de les accompagner j'allais dire
avec des des outils qu'elles ne sont pas
capables de se payer bien évidemment que
c'est pas la bonne échelle de réflexion
mais dans l'opérationnel dans le concret
concret c'est bien ça reste restera le
maire et les services de la ville qui
vont agir ça j'en suis persuadé donc
c'est cette articulation là qu'il faut
que nous mais que nous élaborions
qu'elle soit la plus pertinente et la
plus adaptée au territoire alors je vais
attendre de vous de vous entendre sur
l'amendement du Gouvernement mais voilà
il faut trouver quelque chose suig
générisse pour cette métropole du Grand
Paris la comparaison avec la métropole
de Lyon ne vaut pas si on la rapproche
des territoires des conseils de
territoire donc
monsieur le
ministre si si vous me permettez
monsieur le Président parce que ce débat
est est important moi je vous comparer
la la le cas de figure que dont vous
parliez avec celui de la métropole en
parlant de la taille puisque vous avez
expliqué à un moment que à 400000
habitants c'était pas possible je
voulais vous prendre l'exemple du grand
lion pour vous dire qu'à 1lion2
d'habitants c'était possible bon mais
néanmoins je sais je connais la réalité
de la région de- France bon et donc
justement je veux qu'on puisse au moment
où la loi métropole sera mise en
application et au moment où il y aura
des conseils de territoire que on puisse
avoir la capacité pour le préfet de
région voilà parce que je ne vois pas
d'autres personnalités qui sont en
capacité de de faire de tout d'un coup
regarder en fonction des conseils de
territoire quel sera le bon périmètre
plus large ou plus étroit et dans
l'amendement que je présenterai tout à
l'heure il en est de même pour pour
Marseille où on sait que la mise en
place de la métropole est quelque chose
de compliqué que l'unité en plus entre
la ville de Marseille le secteur d'X le
bassin de de de de de fosse et l'unité
n'est encore moins visible que dans la
région î-defrance et que cette métropole
est à construire dans les
têtes politiquement bon on est on ne
soit pas freiné bon et que par ailleurs
on regarde de ce qui se passe à
Marseille on a de tels problèmes sur la
ville de Marseille qu'on sera peut-être
obligé de concentrer à un moment sur des
des points plus précis physiquement de
de de de la ville de Marseille donc
c'est pour ce laisser cette souplesse
que j'ai introduit cet amendement pour
que le préfet de région puisse au regard
de la loi de son application des
périmètres de conseil de territoire pour
vous dire moi j'avais pensé à un moment
que des bons périmètres pourrai être
ceux des des des CDT en région in- de-
France bon parce que dans les CDT il y
avait la construction collective de d'un
bassin de vie entre des des des des
intercommunalités voir même des communes
qui se regroupaient et qui se dotaient
d'un projet commun et c'est ça qui me
semblait le le plus important bon mais
il y a eu la loi métropole et le
périmètre des CDT ne sera pas forcément
celui des conseils de territoire voilà
bon et donc c'est pour ça que je veux
que en état actuel on puisse laisser au
préfet de la région îne-de-fance la
souplesse nécessaire pour pouvoir en
fonction des situations euh qu'il
connaît voilà euh pouvoir déterminer des
périmètres cohérents et pertinent de
politique de la ville qui ne soient pas
des périmètres microscopiques mais qui
soi à l'échelle de ce que nous nous
allons faire dans d'autres
intercommunalités hors de la région îne-
de-fance où vous avez grosso modo un
bassin de vie avec un ou plusieurs
centres vous pouvez avoir des bassins de
vie multipolaires où on puisse avoir un
périmètre cohérent pour faire du
désenclavement pour faire du
développement économique ou pour faire
des politiques de peuplement voilà
l'idée c'est vrai que vous pourriez
considérer que on laisse une sorte de de
chèque en blanc au préfet bon néanmoins
dans la réalité des des choses on sait
que le préfet de région quel qu'il soit
d'ailleurs quel que soit sa personnalité
a toujours à cœur de trouver les les
bons périmètres en lien avec les élus
moi ce que je veux c'est qu'on se garde
cette souplesse de façon à ce que tout
d'un coup on ne n'exclue pas une commune
ou qu'on ne se retrouve pas dans une
situation d'un d'un binsin de vie d'un
conseil de territoire qui ne soit pas
cohérent avec les bassins de vie qui
empêcherait d'avoir une politique de la
ville qui soit la plus harmonieuse et la
plus solide possible
quoi m' semblit comprendre que vous
formuliez un retrait monsieur Dalier oui
bien merci le l'amendement 68 rectifié
est retiré nous passons à deux
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune tout d'abord
l'amendement 31 présenté par Madame lard
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues comme cela a
déjà été rappelé l'article 5 prévoit les
modalités de mise en œuvre de la
politique de la ville par des contrats
de ville conclus à l'échelle
intercommunal les signataires de ces
contrats sont d'une part l'État et ses
établissements publics d'autre part les
communes uneepci à fiscalité propre
concernée l'amendement que je vous
propose est assez simple il prévoit que
le contrat de ville s'appuie sur un
projet territorial de cohésion ce projet
territorial devrait être coproduit à
l'échelle de l'intercommunalité par tous
les partenaires signataires chacun
devant ensuite mettre en œuvre le projet
de territoire dans le cadre du contrat
au regard de ses
compét bien monsieur le rapporteur vous
présentez votre sous endement en même
temps que vous donnez votre avis je
suppose oui c'est ça monsieur le
président la commission a donné un avis
favorable parce qu' effectivement paraît
pertinent d'avoir un projet de
territoire ça paraît une chose même non
seulement pertinente mais indispensable
simplement la Commission souhaite un
amendement rédactionnel parce que sinon
les choses risquent d'être un petit peu
compliquées c'est-à-dire que au Liu de
au début de la L 4 la Lida commence par
leur leur signataire donc leur ne
désigne plus grand chose donc je propose
qu'on remplace leur signataire par les
signataires du contrat de ville d'cord
monsieur le ministre quel est votre avis
avis favorable sous réserve de la
l'adoption de l' du sous-amendement du
rapporteur endu donc s'il n'y a pas de
demande de prise de parole je mets au
voix le sous-amendement 87 qui est
pour amendement est adopté et je mets au
voit l'amendement 31 ainsis amendé ainsi
amendé qui est pour même vote je vous
remercie il est
adopté nous en venons à l'amendement 70
rectifié présenté par Monsieur viran
donc facilement prolonger ce que dit ma
collègue madame lettardil faut un projet
de territoire il faut associer tous les
parties
prenantes et il faut que
le préfet et quand ça se justifie le
préfet délégué à la ville
et des prérogatives déconcentrées qui
lui permettent de mobiliser
prioritairement le droit commun des
différents services
déconcentrés et en l'adaptant au
besoins dans la pratique nous le savons
tous ici après quelques heures de vol le
niveau de déconcentration de ses préfets
connaî quand même quelques
failles au niveau de leur responsabilité
et de l'autorité direct qu'il peuvent
avoir sur certains services
déconcentrés souvenez-vous le rapport de
la Cour des comptes de juillet sur la
politique de la ville avec les zooms des
chambres régionales des comptes
plusieurs exemples extrêmement précis
montrent qu'effectivement euh on
gagnerait à étendre justement le
l'autorité
déconcentrée des préfets en charge de la
ville notamment ce qui concerne certains
ministères je prends l'exemple de la la
justice pour un exemple que j'ai en tête
sur la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse je pourrais prendre des
exemples bien sûr dans
l'éducation nationale pour s'en tenir à
à ceux qui me viennent immédiatement à
l'esprit
donc je souhaite
que les pouvoirs des des préfets ou
sous-préfets à la ville soient améliorés
d'une manière général je participe à
ceux qui disent l' en rue euh vous
trouverez pas un mer de gauche de droite
du Centre pour dire que c'est pas bien
tous les mêmes vous disent quand même
que la machine est trop centralisée et
donc tant qu'on y
est descendons avec des seuils tout ce
qui peut être les avenances simplifier
la souplesse et cetera on s'en trouvera
gagné jamais un ministre n'a été aussi
loin dans la manière de mobiliser le
droit commun vous pensez bien après
l'intervention que j'ai fait en
discussion générale que si je me permets
d'insister c'est parce que vous êtes là
et on est là au cœur d'un problème réel
qui explique beaucoup trop de remontée
de dossier encore
aujourd'hui monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur dyin quel est votre sur cet
amendement oui alors je je voudrais pas
reprendre l'expression de Monsieur van
derendon quand il est rapporteur en
parlant de la crainte révérentielle
c'est ça dans dans la voie mais je suis
encore obligé de ne pas donner un avis
favorable pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
il me semble que la mobilisation des des
budgets opérationnels relève plus du
règlement que que peut-être de la loi et
puis deuxièmement je suis pas sûr que ça
soit pas déjà satisfait puisque vous
faites vous-même allusion à à des
conventions signées donc il paraît
difficile d'imaginer qu'un préfet
n'exécute pas des des conventions
signées donc je monsieur le à regret
bien sûr je je vous demande le retrait
monsieur le
ministre non moi-même je suis je suis
très très sensible à aux préoccupations
du du sénateur vyendon qui voà qui
partage d'ailleurs les les la viis de
l'ensemble des des parlementaires et et
élus qui sont engagés dans la dans la
politique de la ville euh voilà
l'objectif c'est vraiment cela
bon ces conventions doivent permettre
d'être décliné ensuite sur le terrain
bon avec toutes les difficultés que nous
pourrons
rencontrer néanmoins c'est vrai que ces
conventions ne sont pas des des actes
juridiquement opposable bon et donc nous
sommes quand même en train de faire la
loi VO et autant je pense qu'il faut une
vigilance politique très très forte sur
l'application de ces conventions et sur
leur déclinaison je vais même aller plus
loin monsieur le sénateur sur le fait
que ces conventions je sais les les les
contraintes des des des différents
ministres qui ont beaucoup de beaucoup
de dossiers et pas que les dossiers de
la politique de la ville à gérer que
certains étaient plus enclins à aller
plus vite parce que leurs
administrations étaient déjà
culturellement euh prête à accepter une
territorialisation d'une partie des
crédits ou des moyens humains pour
d'autres je dois avouer je d'autres que
je dont je tirai les noms euh le fait
même qu'on puisse tout d'un coup
décliner des moyens moyens différent
suivant un territoire ou un autre ne
fait pas encore partie du logiciel de le
de de leurs administrations donc
certaines conventions Mo ont été signé
parce qu'ell permettre des avancées mais
elles ne sont pas suffisamment précises
suffisamment concrètes d'autres le sont
très très précisémenton donc on est plus
dans une logique une avancée une autre
façon de de faire
avancer l'état voilà les préfets de
toute façon auront à cœur de mettre en
œuvre il y aura un certain nombre de
circulaire du Premier ministre
d'ailleurs l'avait l'avait engagé en
octobre de l'année
dernière voilà le premier ministre aura
l'occasion de l'affire mais
malheureusement je ne crois pas que ça
relève de la loi voilà donc je vais vous
demander effectivement de retirer votre
amendement
monsieuran
donc je n'avais pas
d'autre but que de faire réfléchir le
titulaire du pouvoir
règlementaire
l'amendement 70 rectifié est retiré euh
nous en venons à quatre amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
tout d'abord l'amendement 32 présenté
par Madame
lard monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues toujours
concernant la mise en œuvre du contr à
ville il est nécessaire de préciser que
le PCI met en place le volet
intercommunal de ses actions volet qui
sera défini en tenant compte des
échelles d'intervention et de la
répartition des compétences entre niveau
communal et intercommunal en effet si la
commune reste évidemment le territoire
d'action privilégié dans la proximité il
n'en est pas moins nécessaire que
l'intercommunalité puisse agir
conjointement à la fois sur des actions
concernant plusieurs quartiers
prioritaires mais aussi sur des publics
prioritair je citais deux exemples en
discussion générale que je connais sur
mon territoire et qui sont appliqué de
cette manière il s'agit par exemple de
l'accompagnement des femmes victimes de
violence ou encore des dispositifs de
réussite éducative qui dès à présent
sont déjà géré sous forme de GP à
l'échelle commun à la demande des
communes qui n'avaient pas la capacité à
les porter seul par ailleurs cet
amendement a un second objectif celui
d'introduire la notion de public
prioritaire dans les actions menées les
actions pourront alors être ciblées sur
les quartiers prioritaires mais aussi
sur ces publics-ci
bien nous passons à l'amendement 88
présenté par Monsieur Dinin au nom de la
commission des affaires
économiques merci monsieur le Président
oui
effectivement le l'alinéa 5 parlant des
des des EPCI dit qu'ils sont compétents
des SPCI compétents en matière de
politique de la ville est chargé du
diagnostic du territoire de la
définition des orientations de la de
l'animation et de la coordination des
contrats de ville mais il ne parle pas
de l'action que peut faire effectivement
un EPCI dans le champ de ses compétences
euh ou dans des champs de de portée
intercommunal donc cet amendement a pour
but de de préciser que effectivement le
le le PCI peut aussi mettre en œuvre des
actions relevant de ses compétences et
cell de porter intercommunal ce qui va
de soi mais qui vaut mieux le dire du
coup je
demanderai euh au aux autres amendements
de se rallier eu de aux autres auteurs
des amendements de se rallier à mon
amendement qui je pense les
satisfait bien monsieur
beccco pour l'amendement numéro 6
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en effet il contribue donc
compléter cette anééa à l'article 5
l'alinéa 5 par une phrase ainsi rédigée
il contribue par ses compétences à la
mise en œuvre des actions définies par
le contrat de ville l'établissement
public de coopération hein c'est ce que
vous dites à l'instant monsieur
rapporteur intercomunal met lui-même en
œuvre des actions définies par le
contrat mais les communes participent à
l'élaboration ce de ce contrat à la
définition des orientations ainsi qu'à
la coanimation du contrat de ville
l'objet de C amendement est donc de
prévoir l'articulation entre le PCI et
les communes
euh et voilà mais je pense que on va un
peu dans le même sens non mais c'est
très bien bien
alors je considère que Monsieur
le le rapporteur a donné son avis
monsieur le ministre
oui je pense qu'effectivement monsieur
le Président que l'amendement du
rapporteur fait une bonne synthèse avec
ces l'ensemble de ces amendements donc
je pense qu'il serait plus serait
préférable qu'il soit retiré au profit
de de l'amendement du rapporteur qu'en
pense madame lettard
alors madame lettard on pense que la
première partie de son amendement est
bien évidemment satisfaite puisqu'elle
est reprise dans l'amendement de
Monsieur dyain et que il est donc
conforme à cette première partie la
seule chose que je voudrais rappeler
c'est que effectivement les actions on
précise bien qu'elles peuvent porter sur
des quartiers prioritaires ou sur des
publics prioritaires ce que je voulais
rappeler c'est que lorsque l'on monte
par exemple des politiques de réussite
éducative ou lorsque l'on lutte contre
les violences saint trfa familiale on ne
s'arrête pas effectivement à la porte du
quartier mais on a bien un diagnostic
territorial qui est fait dans le cadre
de l'élaboration de nos contre ville où
on voit bien et c'est là tout l'intérêt
de ces publics prioritaires c'est que si
les violences intrafamiliales pour
prendre que ce cet aspect là dans le TGI
du valenciénois c'est véritablement une
problématique centrale qui converge avec
les les les public et les quartiers
prioritaire et on voit bien que ce sujet
il est majeur dans notre territoire et
on est le le le TG en France le plus
impacté par cette problématique si on ne
prend pas en compte cette réalité là qui
est en plus complètement convergente
avec les territoires prioritaire on
passe à côté d'un énorme sujet si on
s'arrête au quartier prioritaire
uniquement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que vraiment alors qu'une dynamique
est engagée des publics victimes de
cette réalité pourrait être accompagné
et prévenu on s'interdit de le faire je
crois vraiment que on est vraiment dans
un contrat de ville qui va être élaboré
sous le regard des représentants s
d'État que sont les préfets et les
sous-préfets il y aura pas d'abus dans
ce cadre-là mais faisons en sorte que
par ce membre de phrase là on ne
s'interdise pas des sujets qui sont
aujourd'hui traités et si on ne précise
pas les choses de cette manière
peut-être demain on ne pourra plus le
faire voilà pour l'examen de ce texte
sur la politique de la ville et la
cohésion urbaine texte qui a donc pour
objectif de refonder entièrement la
politique de la ville d'éviter le
saupoudrage des crédits de l'État pour
s'attaquer au quartiers les plus
sensibles de trouver enfin des solutions
structurelles au problème de la
politique de la ville les sénateurs se
sont donc arrêtés dans leur examen à
l'article 7 et il reste 26 amendements à
examiner cet après-midi vous pouvez bien
sûr toujours voir et revoir toutes les
séances sur notre site
publsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 16h30 avec 24h scénat présenté par
Delphine
Girard
toujours novateur en matière de
communication Nicolas Sarkozi a beau se
tenir officiellement h